[Music]
in explaining how the Jews and
Christians must feel themselves subdued
in accord with the quran's commands the
great Islamic scholar Ian kathir quotes
a saying of Muhammad do not initiate the
Salam the greeting of peace to the Jews
and Christians and if you meet any of
them in a Road forc them to the
narrowest alley iban cir then goes on to
outline the notorious and almost
certainly legendary PCT of Umar which
was an agreement made According to
Islamic tradition between the KF Umar
who ruled the Muslims from 634 to 644 ad
and a Christian
Community this p is worth close
examination because despite its very
slight historical value it reflects the
basis the foundation of Islamic law
regarding the treatment of the zum Dees
that is the subjugated people under
Islamic law with remarkably little
variation throughout Islamic history
wherever and whenever Islamic law has
been strictly enforced this is generally
how non-muslims have been treated
working from the full text as Ian cath
has it here are the conditions the
Christians accept in return for what it
terms safety for ourselves children
property and followers of our religion
conditions that according to iban cir
ensured their continued humiliation
degradation and disgrace in accord with
the quran's command the Christians agree
they will will not build a Monastery
Church or a sanctuary for a monk they
will not restore any place of worship
that needs restoration they will not use
such places for the purpose of enmity
against Muslims they will not allow a
spy against Muslims into their churches
and homes or hide deceit or betrayal
against the Muslims they will not
imitate the muslim's clothing caps
turbin sandals hairstyles speech
nicknames and title names they will not
ride on Saddles they will not hang
swords on their shoulders they will not
collect weapons of any kind or carry
those weapons they will not encrypt
their stamps in Arabic they will not
sell liquor you may recall Christians in
Iraq over the last few years ran a foul
of Muslims violently reasserting that
rule they will not teach their children
the Quran they will not publicize
practices of sh that is associating
partners with Allah in worship that is
regarding Jesus as the Son of God in
other words Christians and other
non-muslim all of their religious
practice must be private if not furtive
Christians agreed not to build crosses
on the outside of their churches
demonstrating them putting their books
in public or in Muslim Fairways and
markets again Christian worship must not
be public where Muslims can see it and
become annoyed Christians agree not to
sound bells in churches except
discreetly or raise their voices while
reciting their holy books inside their
churches in the presence of Muslims nor
raise their voices at funerals or like
torches at funeral processions in the
fairways of Muslims or their markets
they will not bury their dead next to
Muslim dead that would be unclean they
will not buy servants who are captured
by Muslims or invite anyone to Sher that
is they're not going to bring the gospel
to anybody new although the Christians
also agree not to prevent any of their
fellows from embracing Islam if they
chose to do so so the Christians can be
the object of prizing but must not
engage in it themselves and of course
they must not beat any Muslim meanwhile
the Christians will allow Muslims to
rest in their churches whether they come
by day or night open the doors of their
houses of worship for the wayfairer and
passer by provide board and food for
those Muslims who come as guests for
three days respect Muslims move from the
places they sit in if they choose to sit
in them like shades of the old Jim Crow
South have the front of their hair cut
wear their customary clothes wherever
they are wear belts around their waist
these rules are so that a Muslim can
recognize that a non-muslim is coming
and doesn't make the mistake of greeting
him with assalamu alayum peace be upon
you which is the Muslim greeting
reserved only for a fellow Muslim the
Christians also agree to be guides for
Muslims and refrain from breaching their
privacy in their homes so Muslims can
come to a Christian home and demand to
be put up there for three days but the
Christians of course don't dare to go to
muslim's homes the Christians swore if
we break any of these promises that we
set for your benefit against ourselves
then our zumma or dimma promise of
protection is broken and you are allowed
to do with us what you were allowed to
do to people of defiance and Rebellion
that is kill them these are still the
parameters of Islamic law regarding
non-muslims to this day for more
information go to this
website